fortnite is ruining everything that i
love
i have nothing left they took superman
the
master chief and now they've come for my
boy naruto
[Music]
why
why did it exist
who asked for this
who said yes what's the ulterior motive
who needs to be held responsible who do
we need to line up in the in the
backyard with our eyes tied okay
i'm gonna give you 30 seconds to delete
this fortnight i know you're listening
here look at that look at this photo
tell me how you feel
i don't feel good i don't feel good at
all i hate it
it doesn't matter obviously i don't care
at all
but why do i hate it
so much
ah
we live in the darkest timeline again
the thing is like all right martha's
cheap shirt i love halo as a kid we
didn't we all did but at least he had a
gun right cut to this
he's doing the meme run that's so that's
hilarious oh my god welcome to the
pewdiepie channel where we don't play
video games and where we just complain
about them please
subscribe industrial revolution
has gone too far
oh my god this also ruins the song that
we wrote they said i would never be
bowling but i literally have a ball
fortnite is plagiarizing my music we
never release this song because youtube
is just going to delete it anyway
[Music]
explain yourself
epic games
and maybe it's just lyrics uh goku after
finding out naruto god in fortnite
no just some crossovers just should
never be done sakura crying in the
background while sasuke is dancing to
caramel dancing
[Music]
don't copy strike come on oh god
you know there's a lot of pent up anger
here for me because this has been going
on for a while sure i love naruto as a
kid but it doesn't matter now
another thing they did was the
balenciaga skin i didn't see a lot of
people talk about this maybe i'm the
only one who cares but i don't really
wear balance tiago i wear tsuki only i
appreciate what they're doing they're
kind of posting fashion you can't really
tell sometimes if something is a meme or
if it's actually balanced real
balanciaga you know what i mean and i
appreciate that that's a good level of
posting they're sourcing fashion why pay
half a pound for uh an ikea bag when you
can pay a thousand right if they can
make money out of people this is dumb
i respect that i really do and then when
they make shoes they look like the
mcdonald's
surprise case then yeah
that's awesome what the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
[Music]
you see what i mean with the fever dream
[Music]
it can't just be me okay all right
here's why i hate this fashion
extraordinaire there's two outcomes and
it all depends on intent and i don't
know the intent so i don't know but like
they released a bunch of clothing
alongside the fortnite skin collab you
can get some real life skin guys
fortnite kids there's real sport light
skins
i only have to pay 550 pounds for it
and it's the white hoodie that says
fortnite
that in itself is hilarious i just don't
know if it's intentional or not and
that's why it's really bothering me i
need to know because i either hate it or
love it and i i don't know which side i
want to be on at this point they really
just didn't even they just put fortnite
they're like all right we're going to
work with epic games or should we do we
have a team of designers all lined up
all right what do you what do you got oh
i made this like really cool
hand-drawn type of deal design that
really represent all this
that's garbage all right what do you got
i just put the fortnite logo and then
our logo alright that's it 500 buckaroos
let's go
come on come on
stop it get somehow fine
they ruined balinciaga fine fortnite
what else can you possibly ruin for me
oh that's right they did a college
collab as well
that's cool
because it's already ruined uh it's
already way too popular but like why the
kids like cars
i mean it's pretty cool skin i'm not
gonna lie 10 bucks for internet skin is
why is that so funny how much was the
policy i'll get in it's ten dollars
basically
oh my god cool so what's funny about
this is that i now officially have
a fortnight tattoo
it hurts man i can only laugh because i
any other emotion is just too sad man
goddammit fortnite i hate you what are
they gonna do next if they collide with
ikea it's over in before my dad
collapsed with fortnite cool thanks for
ruining my dad fortnight anyway
subscribe for more epic videos see you
tomorrow bye bye